[Music]
it's easy to grow up with a sense that
our feelings are reliable guides to
ourselves the people around us and the
world at large we can call this
optimistic thesis that clear pain theory
of the mind imply that we are able to
look out onto the world pretty much as
if through an undistorted and
blemish-free
pane of glass yet a long tradition in
philosophy has sought to warn us of a
far trickier truth the school of thought
known as skepticism that began in
ancient Greece in the 3rd century BC
proposed that a great many of our solid
seeming sensory first impressions should
not be assumed to be accurate and must
instead be submitted to the Boreas
process of rational unscrambling far
from our minds being clear pains
they're full of scratches blind spots
and warps to be wise therefore Mars for
the skeptics to strive to be permanently
vigilant about how much were inclined to
misunderstand reality by trusting our
first feelings one tiny instance of our
distorting Minds that particularly
fascinated the Greeks was a strange
phenomenon that occurs when a stick is
partially submerged in water it
immediately seems as if the stick angles
into a V just at the point where it
meets the surface but if we pull the
stick out we'll see that it's of course
still straight the skeptics took this
tiny example as a gateway to a vast
truth that our senses are humbling ly
fallible the way things appear to us is
often simply not how they in fact really
are skeptical ideas were to be the
leading force behind the development of
modern science in the middle of the 16th
century the Polish philosopher and
astronomer Copernicus demonstrated that
whatever our senses might have suggested
to us for hundreds of thousands of years
according to logical reasoning the truth
is that the Sun does not in fact revolve
around the earth but the skeptics
weren't only interested in the errors we
fall into when doing astronomy they were
fascinated by our tendencies to fall
into error
not personal lives under the influence
of our emotions for example our minds
are seldom free of the influence of
moods a kind of emotional whether that
scuds over our mental horizons normally
without us having any understanding of
where these moods have come from when
they might lift or even that they exist
however these moods can have a decisive
impact on our ideas we might in one mood
consider ourselves fortunate look
brightly at the future and feel grateful
to those around us and then a few hours
later without anything in the outer
world haven't changed another mood might
lead us to a wholesale re-evaluation of
almost everything about us devilishly
part of what it means to be subject to a
mood is not to realize that we are in
its grip we simply feel that our friends
whom we like quite a lot yesterday and
no good in our job which once offered us
so much is absurd tiredness can be a
particularly powerful agent that
silently and invisibly perverts our
judgment the 19th century skeptic
Friedrich Nietzsche remarked when we are
tired we are attacked by ideas we
thought we'd conquered long ago though
crucially is extremely rare and
counterintuitive to judge that it really
might be tiredness that's affecting our
outlook rather than certain objective
facts in the world we are keener to
conclude that we've suddenly developed a
deep resentment against humanity we
urgently need to get to bed lust can
similarly play with our judgment leading
us to see sensitivity kindness and a
decent alternative to our current
partner where there is in truth just an
exceptionally beautiful profile and
perhaps not much else as the German
sceptical philosopher Arthur
Schopenhauer wryly concluded immediately
after population the devil's laughed
about appreciating how flawed our minds
our forms the basis upon which the score
emotional scepticism is founded this
skill defined is of cautious awareness
of the misleading power of our feelings
on our judgment having survey the
fragilities of our minds
the ancient Greeks sceptical
philosophers recommended that we learn
to develop an attitude of what they
called epoch II translated as reserve or
suspension of judgment aware of our
tendencies to error we were never to
rush into decisions we were to let our
ideas settle so that they could be
re-evaluated at different points in time
and we were to be especially vigilant
about the impact of sexual excitement
and tiredness on the formation of our
plans for a range of historical reasons
we've collectively been extremely
reluctant to recognize the benefits of
emotional scepticism the romantic
movement of the 19th century work we've
dusted a guy Ling but often disastrous
notions that it's our emotions that it's
always our finest guides to the truth
but we will have gone a long way to
counteract the problems of our minds if
we sometimes do ourselves the honor of
not listening to our feelings instead
waiting for certain and helpful moods to
pass and accepting that we are at heart
highly viscous bags of saline solution
who stare out at reality via a highly
unreliable and distorted pane of glass
and must therefore frequently suspend
judgment moderate our impulses who watch
over our diet and strive to get to bed
Darley
you